en el vídeo anterior lo que vimos es que
un campo vectorial en ocasiones puede
ser escrito como el gradiente el
gradiente de un campo escalar digamos
efe
ok y otra forma de decirlo es que esto
sería igual a la parcial de f mayúscula
respecto de x x el vector y más la
parcial de f respecto de ye por el
vector jota y simplemente estoy
escribiendo lo de múltiples formas para
que recuerden lo que es lo que es el
gradiente pero bien vimos que nuestro
campo vectorial es el gradiente de un
campo escalar y entonces lo yo lo
llamamos conservativo efe
es un campo vectorial conservativo
correcto
así es como también podemos llamarlo y
también nos dice que esto fue la parte
más importante respecto al vídeo
anterior que la integral de línea de f
entre dos puntos déjenme déjenme dibujar
a cada dos puntos por ejemplo
vamos a pintar los ejes muy bien este es
el eje y eje x y ya tenemos el plano muy
bien entonces si tenemos un punto
digamos este que pinte aquí y este otro
punto y tengo dos trayectorias
diferentes entre dichos puntos digamos
esta es la trayectoria uno que pinto con
amarillo y este vamos a llamarle c uno
hay que ponerle una dirección a esta a
esta curva y ahora tengo quizás no sé
una verde c 2 una curva c 2 que va de
esta forma en esa dirección lo
importante es que los dos empiecen en el
mismo lugar y terminen en el mismo lugar
entonces vimos que la integral de línea
es independiente de la trayectoria entre
esos dos puntos así que en este caso la
integral de línea a lo largo de c 1 d
efe punto de r es igual es igual a la
integral de línea de c 2 ps2 a lo largo
de la trayectoria c 2 d
efe punto de r es decir si tenemos un
potencial en la región y podemos estar
en todos los puntos entonces la integral
de línea entre dos puntos es
independiente de la trayectoria esto es
lo bueno de tener un campo conservativo
verdad
en realidad es una extensión muy
importante porque puede puede que les
parezca obvia y ya escrito esto aquí
pero voy a reordenar un poco la ecuación
déjenme por ejemplo es reescribir esto
en naranja tengo la integral de línea de
f sobre c 1 punto de ere y ahora
restamos lo que tenemos del lado derecho
menos la integral de línea a lo largo de
c 2 d efe punto de r y por supuesto esto
tiene que ser igual a 0 ahora todo lo
que hemos hecho es tomar lo más
relevante del vídeo anterior y restamos
esto en ambos lados de la ecuación
ahora bien aprendimos también hace unos
varios vídeos que si restamos una
integral de línea de un campo vectorial
no de un campo escalares de un campo
vectorial en la dirección de cierta
trayectoria entonces aprendimos que la
integral de líneas sobre digamos c2 de f
punto de f punto de r es igual a menos
la integral de línea de menos de 2
efe punto de r donde menos de 2 denota
la misma trayectoria que recorre c 2
pero en dirección contraria por ejemplo
c 2 la escrita la menos c 2 le
escribiría algo así digamos hay que
hacerlo en este color
- c 2
lo ponemos así es la misma línea pero
con flechitas en la dirección contraria
verdad así que ignoramos las las
flechitas verdes y ahora nos fijamos en
las flechitas de este nuevo color
podríamos reescribir poniendo el menos
del lado contrario como menos la
integral de línea a lo largo de c 2 d
efe punto de ser igual a la integral de
de línea a lo largo de menos c 2 d
efe punto de r todo lo que hemos hecho
es cambiar el menos al otro lado verdad
multiplicando por menos 1 la ecuación
así que si reemplazamos esto en la
ecuación original que estoy marcando
ok esta esta es la parte que queremos
reemplazar así que permítanme hacer esto
voy a escribir esta parte que ya
teníamos la integral de c-1 de f punto
de r y aquí vamos a sustituir con más la
integral de línea sobre menos 2 verdad
esto es lo que lo que observamos en esta
parte en verde y que estamos en marcando
entonces sustituimos esta expresión por
la integral de línea bueno vamos a
ponerle más la integral de línea a lo
largo del camino inverso verdad entonces
sumamos la integral de línea sobre menos
c 2 de f punto de r y esto es igual a 0
perfecto ahora hay algo interesante
miremos qué es la combinación de estos
caminos porque de m de c 1 y menos de
dos porque si uno empieza en este punto
déjenme ponerle en morado muy bien se
mueve de de ese punto a lo largo de c 1
y llega hasta este otro punto y ahora
hacemos menos c 2 que empieza en este
punto donde terminó c 1 y llega al punto
original es decir se completa una vuelta
a lo largo de una curva cerrada si
combinamos estas dos suma o esta suma de
dos sumandos haciendo el el trayecto
inverso de c 2 entonces tenemos un
camino cerrado verdad como ya observamos
así que esto es equivalente a la
integral de línea a lo largo de una
curva cerrada de una curva cerrada y así
es como la denotamos es decir podríamos
llamar a este camino c 1 más menos c 2
muy bien esto podría ser que señalamos
hace uno y hace dos como parte de
nuestro recorrido donde se dos va en
dirección contrario verdad por supuesto
aquí la hipótesis es que es un campo
conservativo y esto que escribimos como
un camino cerrado en realidad es sólo
una reescritura de lo que ya teníamos
verdad aquí hay que agregar
efe punto de r y esto va a ser igual a
cero y esto es nuestro resultado final
de este vídeo lo más importante podemos
verlo como un corolario de de las
conclusiones que ya hemos hecho en
vídeos anteriores verdad así que ahora
sabemos que si tenemos un campo
vectorial que tiene que es el gradiente
de un campo escalar en alguna región o
tal vez en todo el plano xy ya esto es a
lo que le llamamos el potencial de f
verdad el potencial de f a menudo va a
ser negativo pero bueno para fines de
este vídeo no importa
en realidad el gradiente es de un campo
escalar y eso nos dice que es un campo
conservativa un campo vectorial
conservativa y entonces lo que nos dice
es que la integral de línea de f no
depende de las trayectorias y por eso es
que un una línea cerrada nos da como
resultado que la integral sobre una
línea cerrada en realidad no hay otra
cosa más que sea cero la integral de
línea de f sobre esa sobre ese lazo
cerrado verdad porque es independiente
de la ruta eso es a lo que concluimos
entonces si has visto algo como esto por
ejemplo
efe punto de r sobre una línea cerrada y
alguien te pide evaluar esta integral
sabiendo que es conservativa pues
entonces es el gradiente de una función
escalar y por supuesto ya sabes
inmediatamente que es cero lo cual
simplifica muchísimo las cuentas